governor sysolak holding a round table  today focusing on assistance for  businesses and bringing back our economy  lieutenant governor kate marshall  treasurer zach conine and a group of  small business owners also  on that virtual call are concerns  assisting businesses and employees  who test positive for coronavirus and  when small business owners and employees  can get the vaccine  as part of the governor's economic plan  he announced his intention  to allocate an additional 50 million  dollars to provide direct grant  assistance to small businesses  and create a small business advocacy  center  in addition to this resource center  connecting you with those grants we also  need to make sure that going forward  you can call and we have a back phone  with the pets grant pandemic emergency  technical support they received  application for more than 13  000 businesses representing a need of  almost  150 million dollars